Die zwei Sprechstunden.
Genau, so eine Telefonie, irgendwas Service, Sprachentsatz.
Das war dann so ein Wochenendprojekt von so einem Google-Entwickler, dass er das mal schnell baut, hat sich mit zwei Twitter-Leuten zusammengesetzt und die haben es mal gebastelt halt. Ich fand es einfach schön zu sehen, dass Menschen da sind, weltweit, die sich Gedanken machen, wie kann man die Lebensqualität der Menschen vor Ort entweder halbwegs aufrechterhalten oder zumindest versuchen zu verbessern.
Also eine kleine Leitung nach außen, obwohl die Mächtigen des Landes beschlossen haben, das sollt ihr eigentlich nicht mehr können, wir wollen euch eigentlich mal alles abschalten. Das ist genau das, was wir heute hier in dieser Sendung besprechen. Und von den Zweien bleibt uns noch eine im Chaosradio, heute mit Wetterfrosch, Elektra Wagenrad und Herrn Urbach. Es geht um Internet in Krisengebieten, das heißt Gebiete, wo beschlossen wurde, hey, hier soll keiner mehr kommunizieren können, dort doch noch genau das irgendwie möglich zu machen. Wir haben heute schon ein paar Ansätze gehört. Es ging mit Mesh-Netzwerken, also einfach Plastikkisten ins Land geworfen werden, die kommunizieren dann wie magisch untereinander oder alte Rechner mit Modems werden in irgendwelche Lagerhallen gestellt und können angerufen werden. Und wir haben gehört, dass in einem Wochenende ein Dienst gebaut wurde, wo man einfach anrufen kann und dann zu twittern. Es geht also um kreative Lösungen, wie Kommunikation aufrechterhalten werden kann, wie Infrastruktur für Kommunikation gebaut werden kann. Und eigentlich seid auch ihr gefragt, ruft bitte an, wenn ihr auch ein Beispiel für so einen kreativen Umgang mit Technik habt. Und während ihr das tut, werden wir noch eine weitere Musik hören. Die hat der Herr Urbach rausgesucht und ich habe schon wieder vergessen, irgendwas mit schwedischem Tanzorchester war es.
Das ist das Diablo Swing Orchestra mit dem Ballrock Boogie.
Und was ist genau was? Es ist auf jeden Fall Creative Commons Musik, weil das muss es sein, um hier in der Sendung gespielt zu werden.
Musik aus Schweden, von daher hinreichend wahnsinnig, wie ich so in schwedischer Musik gewohnt bin. Ich habe mir meine Chefin vor ein paar Jahren hingeknallt, mach mal da Werbetext, für habe ich gemacht und ja.
Ach ja, also hinreichend wahnsinnig. Hinreichend wahnsinnig ist ein schönes Prädikat, das ich in Zukunft öfter vergeben möchte. Vom Diablo-Swinger-Kristall, der Balrog-Boogie hier im Chaosradio Aufritz, empfohlen von Herrn Urbach, der meinte, er müsste mal ein bisschen schwedisch Musik hier zu Gehör bringen. Wir sprechen aber über andere Krisen, nämlich über Krisen, wo es kein Internet mehr gibt. Wir haben halt schon auch vorgestellt ein Projekt, um Internet in Gegner zu bringen oder nicht Internet. Eigentlich geht es darum, Kommunikationen in die Gegner zu bringen mittels eines, wie heißt es Elektra, Village Talks, Village Telco?
Meshpoteto heißt das Gerät und das Projekt heißt Village Telco. Die Webseite ist villagetelco.org. Übrigens habe ich vergessen, darauf hinzuweisen, es gibt ein One-Minute-Explainer-Video auf YouTube, das ist verlinkt von der Webseite, das ist großartig, kann ich nur empfehlen.
Eine Minute Zeit, dann habt ihr es auf jeden Fall verstanden. Und Reinhard angerufen hat eine kurze Frage. Hallo und guten Abend.
Eine zweite Frage, die sich noch eben ergeben hat. Wie heißt der Titel, mit dem ich das bei YouTube finden kann? Die andere Sache ist, ich habe unter Village Telco nachgeguckt im Internet und habe euch nur in Englisch gefunden.
Habt ihr noch irgendwie eine deutsche Seite? Die dritte Sache ist, mit welcher Hardware arbeitet er zentral mit diesem WLAN-Funkchip? Gut, also es sind internationale Anstrengungen, diese Entwicklung. Sie richtet sich nicht speziell an Deutschland, deswegen gibt es keine deutsche Seite. Es ist leider alles in Englisch.
Aber man könnte sich durchaus hinstellen und das mal übersetzen, oder?
Ja, könnte man tun. Aber Deutschland ist eben kein Entwicklungsgebiet, von daher konzentrieren wir uns da nicht drauf. Die andere Frage ist der Chip, der da innen drin, das ist ein Single-Chip-System, also ein SoC, System on Chip. Und der stammt von der Firma Ateros. Der kann WLAN nach 800, 2.11, B und G.
Rainer, Fragen beantwortet?
Eine Zusatzfrage, wenn ich nachhaken darf, technisch. Es gibt diesen einen Big-C-C-Chip.
Okay, nein, nein, nein. Das wird zu technisch, das wird für alle anderen, die jetzt am Radio, am Rundfunk, am Fankstrieger sitzen, können dann nicht mehr folgen. Stell die Frage einfach hier direkt, du kannst ja auf die Webseite gehen und dann deine Mail schreiben, okay? Danke. Also ihr könnt gerne anrufen, wenn ihr Fragen habt, das ist wirklich überhaupt gar kein Problem. Aber wir sollten schon sagen, im Rahmen dessen bleiben, dass wir zumindest halbwegs dem Gespräch folgen können. Aber dann gilt wie gesagt gerne. 0331 70 97 110 Genau, über tiefergehende technische Gespräche wollen wir uns allerdings dann an dieser Stelle nicht auslassen. Was immer noch so bedeutet, die Kontakt haben zu Leuten, die in Libyen oder Ägypten jetzt sitzen oder gesessen haben und dort mal über die Situation berichten können.
Oder in China.
Oder in China zum Beispiel. Die Leute, die in China schon mal waren, das finde ich auch immer spannend. Ich habe es bis jetzt noch von Einanlo gehört und das auch noch ganz kurz. Aber so Leute, die in China waren, dort mal das Internet erlebt haben. Das würde mich wirklich mal interessieren.
Na, da kann ich die unterstehen.
Ah, okay, warum sagt ihr das nicht gleich?
Ich glaube, ich hatte es voll schon.
Also jetzt ist es natürlich so, eigentlich sollen die Leute anrufen. Aber gut, erzähl mal.
Nein, du warst noch nicht da, die Leute sollen anrufen.
Also wir können jetzt ja auf einen Anruf warten oder...
Während ihr anruft, erzählt Elektra schon mal, was sie in China erlebt hat.
Also ich war in Shenzhen, das ist in der Nähe von Hongkong und ich war in Weijing. Ich habe das Internet benutzt, vor allem über das Mobiltelefon. Das funktioniert sehr gut und ist auch sehr, sehr preiswert, muss ich sagen. Man kriegt da eine GPS-Verbindung und die Gebühren sind sehr, sehr niedrig. Man kann erstaunlicherweise die gesamte westliche Presse in der englischen Sprache lesen. Das ist kein Problem. Man kann auch Dinge mit Google suchen, wobei die Chinesen ihre eigene Suchmaschine haben, die heißt Baidu.
Die sind aber auch powered bei Google, oder?
Ich glaube nicht, nein. Das haben sie nicht.
Das ist eine eigene Entwicklung.
Das ist auch ein Konkurrenzprodukt. Man kann die gesamten westlichen Medien lesen. Allerdings, die Seite, die man nicht aufrufen kann, ist die von Chaos Computer Club, die ist blockiert. Und alles, was mit Wiki drin ist, kann man auch nicht aufrufen, weil da könnte jemand eigene Inhalte einbringen, die dann andere Leute sehen und das will man nicht haben. Und deswegen geht auch die Village Telco Google Group, die kann man zum Beispiel vom chinesischen Internet aus auch nicht lesen.
Wie ist das mit so Tettdiensten?
Hab ich auch verwendet. Jabbah geht wunderbar, kein Problem.
Okay, wo ist jetzt die große Firewall, von der wir alle sprechen? Entschuldigung?
Die große Firewall filtert vor allem bestimmte Internetinhalte aus, die unerwünscht sind.
Okay, das ist aber schon eine relativ clevere Einrichtung, also man kann eigentlich alles machen, nur sozusagen, wenn es ans Eingemachte geht, da schreiten sie dann ein, aber es ist nicht so, dass es eine Einschränkung im täglichen Bedarf ist, das Ausblenden.
Ein Software-Entwickler, der zum Beispiel...
Eine runde Mate auf mich. Eine runde Mate gibt heute von Elektra aus, weil ihr ein technisches Gerät ein Geräusch im Radio gemacht habt. Unglaublich.
Ich hab die Lautstärke auf dem Radio gesehen.
Okay, also im täglichen Bedarf hat man da eine Einschränkung oder nicht?
Ja, hat man. Gravierend. Man kann die ganzen schönen Filmchen auf YouTube nicht sehen. Kann man nicht. Unter alle anderen Filmchen von Vimeo und so weiter kann man auch nicht sehen. Man kann zum Beispiel nur bestimmte Dienste von Google nutzen. Also alles, was irgendwie interaktiv ist, alles, was Web 2.0 ist, wo man einfach Probleme ist, was publizieren kann. WordPress zum Beispiel, der Begriff WordPress wird gefiltert. Also jeglicher Blog, der WordPress beinhaltet, in der URL, der funktioniert einfach nicht.
Wir lieben China. Die wäre wahrscheinlich die bessere URL für einen Blog, was man von da betreiben kann.
Ja und wenn man die WordPress Installationen macht, sollte man eben den WordPress-Order umbenennen und keinen Link haben, der das Wort WordPress enthält, dann geht es wahrscheinlich auch.
Manchmal kann es so einfach sein. Heute kreativer Umgang mit Technik, um Internet und Kommunikation zu ermöglichen. Wetterfrau, schreibt uns noch ein Beispiel aus Kosovo.
In den 90ern war der Balkan ja auch ein Resengebiet geteilt und da hat man unter anderem die Tete Phonleitungen zwischen den beiden Landesteilen gehabt. Die konnten einander nicht anrufen, Familien waren sozusagen getrennt, konnten nicht spontan sozusagen oder auch wissen, wie es einander geht, aber weiterhin ins Ausland telefonieren. Und zu der Zeit war das jetzt vor diesen ganzen Internetmodems, wie wir sie eigentlich kennen, sondern noch so diese Mailbox-Zeit und es gab da auch schon in der Tat einzelne Computer, die an so Mailbox-Netzwerken teilnehmen konnten. Die konnten, wie gesagt, nicht im Landesinneren zwischen den beiden Hälften kommunizieren, aber wiederum in der eigenen Hälfte und ins Ausland. Und dann wurde in Berlin im Bielefeld von einigen Aktivisten ein Mailbox, wie das im klassischen 80er-Sinde war, betrieben, wo eben die Nachrichten ausgetauscht werden konnten. Eine Mailbox, das war... Das Rauschen und Fiepen, was wir am Anfang der Sendung hatten, dass ja sozusagen diese Einwahl eines Modems und eben durch Rauschen und Fiepen auf eine Telefonader werden da einfach Daten übertragen, dadurch dass das mal eben länger oder kürzer fiept oder höher oder tiefer in der Frequenz. Und so wurden halt hauptsächlich Texte und ja direkte Mitteilungen übertragen und wohl auch innerhalb des Landes weiterverteilt ausgedruckt und dann in andere Städte gebracht sozusagen in ein alternatives Nachrichtensystem, basierend auf Telefon, Ausdrucken und zwischen die beiden Landeselfen.
Ja, man hat da eine Mailbox, da schickt man irgendwelche Informationen hin und diese Mailbox tauscht sich dann irgendwann mit einer anderen Mailbox aus und so vernetzen sich sich alle miteinander und updaten sich gegenseitig. Also es ist dezentral und deswegen auch nicht so leicht anzugreifen.
Und sehr großartig ist es, wir genau solche Technologie gerade verwenden möchten, um für Gebiete, wo das Netz abgeschaltet wird, Backup-Infrastruktur zu bauen mit neueren Protokollen, mit dieser alten Technologie des Synchronisieren. Also wir sind gerade dabei, das irgendwie in einen Topf zu werfen, kräftig umzurühren, wieder auszuschütten und ja, also ohne diese Mailbox-Erfahrung aus den 80ern, könnten wir diese Technologie jetzt gerade nicht bauen, die hoffentlich demnächst fertig ist.
Wir haben im Vorfeld drüber gesprochen, dass das low-leveligste, also das niedrigstechnischste, was wir gefunden haben, war irgendwie USB-Sticks werden umhergetragen, um Internet zu simulieren. Kann man kurz erklären, wie das geht?
Genau, also erstens gab es in Afrika auch mal so einen kleinen Test zwischen zwei Ländern, Datentransfer zu machen. Was ist schneller, die klassische Internetversorgung dort oder eine Brieftaube mit einem USB-Stick? Die Brieftaube hatte natürlich einen wesentlich höheren Datendurchsatz. Das würde vielleicht in manchen Regionen hier in Deutschland auch noch mal der Fall sein. Und ferner gibt es sozusagen auch Regionen, wo Internet gar nicht leicht erschlossen werden kann. Da gibt es keine Telefonleitungen, da ist vielleicht auch bei Funk schwierig oder man hat einfach schlichtweg nicht das Geld. Dort kann man natürlich von Computer zu Computerdaten austauschen. Ganz, ganz früher, bevor es das Internet gab, hat man ja Magnetbänder irgendwie zwischen Computern ausgetauscht und mal eine Kopie irgendwie auf die andere Seite des Atlantiks geschickt. Heute kann das ja schon ein USB-Stick sein. Und da gibt es dann wirklich einen kleinen Schul-Server in der Region Afrikas, wo Leute ihre Mails haben, wo Leute vielleicht auch Terminal-Computer haben, dort ihre Mails empfangen und schreiben, aber sie haben keinen Internetanschluss. Sie haben keine Internetleitung. Sie haben quasi eine Art Briefträger oder mehrere, die mit einem USB-Stick vorbeikommen und den sozusagen an einem Ende von der Einverbindung zum anderen Ende, wo es eben Internet gibt, hin und her tragen und damit nehmen sie sozusagen neue Mails mit, die reinkommen, Antworten, die formuliert wurden, wieder mit in die andere Richtung und dann werden sie, wenn er den USB-Stick das nächste Mal an der Universität anschließt, die Internet hat, verschickt.
Und selbst das planen wir in unserer Backup-Strategie ein, dass mit USB-Sticks die Rechner gesendet werden.
Ich habe dazu eine Nachfrage. Also ich kann mir natürlich jetzt so vorstellen, klar, ich nehme jetzt irgendwie von zu Hause den USB-Stick mit, gehe zu einem anderen Rechner und stecke ihn rein und kopiere die Wortdokumente darunter und dann könnt ihr das da lesen. Oder gibt es tatsächlich ein Protokoll?
Also ich stecke den USB-Stick rein, dann das Software zieht sich das runter und verteilt das quasi, als ob man aus dem Netz kommen würde, beziehungsweise ein, zwei Lösungen davon zusammengeschweißt, die das dann ermöglichen.
Elektra, du wolltest noch?
Es gibt noch eine Steigerung davon. Es gibt Busse, die durch Gegenden fahren, wo relativ schlechte Anbindung ist oder gar keine Anbindung existiert und die haben dann WLAN-Gerät an Bord und immer wenn die irgendwo halten, wo sie regelmäßig vorbeikommen, um Passagiere aufzunehmen, wird lokal drahtlos werden Daten übertragen, also der Bus kommt vorbei, dann wird der lokale Ordner synchronisiert, es werden Daten hin und her gereicht, der Bus fährt weiter und die Daten werden transportiert.
Das digitale Briefträger.
Mir fällt gerade noch ein Fun-Fact ein, diese Berechnung von wegen Brieftaube oder Internet. In Kanada hat das mal jemand gemacht, weil da die Internetgebühren wohl relativ groß sind und hat er ausgerechnet, dass es, wenn er einen Film haben will, den er sich online ausleitet, ist es wohl billiger, eine SSD-Festplatte zu kaufen, den Film mal draufspielen zu lassen, dann zu ihm schicken zu lassen, als es tatsächlich übers Netz runterzuleiten, weil die Datentarife dann wirklich so extrem ist.
Das ist um die neuen Datentarife. Also in Kanada oder generell Nordamerika denkt man generell drüber nach, die Datenträfe deutlich zu erhöhen. In Kanada hat jetzt der erste Prider damit angefangen und da ist es wirklich billiger, eine 750 Gigabyte SSD-Platte zu kaufen und den Film darauf zu kopieren und sich per Post zuschicken zu lassen. Per Express, glaube ich sogar. Per Express, als das übers Netz zu machen.
Es gibt ein klassisches Beispiel aus der Computerliteratur. Man sollte die Datenübertragungsrate eines LKWs, der mit Festplatten beladen ist, nicht unterschätzen.
Kannst du Internet?
archive.org, die Webseite kennt ihr sicher nicht alle. Die haben früher mal das gesamte Internet archiviert. Als ich diese Seite kennengelernt habe, das war so um das Jahr 2000, 2001, war ihr gesamter Datenbestand 4 Terabyte. Damals haben sie wirklich alles, was es im Internet öffentlich erreichbar gab, also auch Treiberdownloads.
Das steht seit neuestem bei mir unterm Schreibtisch als Backup.
Ich war neu schockiert, ich habe nicht meine alte Webseite wiedergefunden.
Alte Vergehen. Wir waren gerade dabei stehen geblieben, in Gebiete, die kein Netz haben, das zu bringen. Notwendigerweise oder in der Not auch damit, dass wir USB-Sticks hin und her fahren. Herr Oberach hat davon gesprochen, dass ihr jetzt ein Paket zusammenbastelt. Wie genau soll das aussehen? Oder an so einem Standard arbeitet, um solche Gebiete wieder zu versorgen?
Genau, ein Survival-Kit. Wie das genau aussieht, kann ich noch gar nicht wirklich sagen, weil wir gerade in der Konzeptionierungsphase erst sind, die aber schon sehr weit vorgeschritten ist. Im Endeffekt geht es dabei um Synchronisieren über sowohl Modemverbindungen, als auch USB-Sticks, als auch über WLAN-Verhandlungen, WLAN-Meshnetzen, die sich dann selbst organisieren. Das Ganze so idiotensicher, dass es jeder benutzen kann, weil oft schallt die Technologie daran, dass Menschen es nicht benutzen können. Wir sind noch nicht fertig damit. Ich weiß nicht, wie lange wir brauchen. Ich hoffe, wir brauchen nicht allzu lange, dass wir es recht bald einsetzen können, dass wir alternative Netzstrukturen aufbauen können, also das alles dezentralisieren können, dass wir eigene Netze betreiben können, dass wir zur Not einfach einen USB-Stick von A nach B tragen und somit Daten in großen Mengen weitergeben können. Ja, das ist der Plan. Da haben wir auch als Protokoll uns das gute alte News-Protokoll ausgesucht.
Das ist also auch irgendwie, was eigentlich nicht mehr benutzt wird, oder?
Es wird noch von ein paar Leuten benutzt. Auch da ist der Plan, es so zu bauen, dass US-Basic-Reinschieben in den Rechnerbooten funktioniert. Und dass er auch alles vorkonfiguriert ist mit einem schicken Webfront. Und dass es halt für den Menschen auch so wie bei Facebook benutzen würde. Was im Hintergrund passiert, ist ihm scheißegal. Und so muss es auch sein.
Ich bin nach wie vor der Ansicht, dass ihr beide euch mal zusammensetzen würdet. Ich glaube, da könnte irgendwas bei rauskommen. Wir sind aber übrigens vor einer guten Stunde, haben wir gesagt, wir wollen noch klären, wie die Leute in Ägypten, das ist ja das Projekt, also Telecomix, wo Herr Urbach von herkommt, die Qualle, also eine Organisation, die sich als Qualle beschreibt, die haben ja gemacht, dass die Leute in Ägypten, die kein Internet mehr haben, einfach wo anrufen konnten und dann sozusagen sich eingewählt haben in das Internet. Das Problem ist, die haben gar kein Internet. Die müssen ja irgendwie die Rufennummer bekommen, wo sie anrufen können, um sich das Internet anzuwählen. Wie habt ihr das hingekriegt? Habt ihr so, wie es damals gemacht wurde, so Flugzeuge, die so Zettel abwerfen, so rufen mich an?
Die waren zu teuer. Wir haben Faxe geschickt.
Nicht dein Ernst?
Doch, wir haben Faxe geschickt. Wohin? An wen? An Universitäten, also gerade die Informatik-Virultäten, Bibliotheken, Krankenhäuser, Internetcafés.
Okay.
Also wir haben sie dahin geschickt, wo wir der Meinung waren, dass die Leute mit was anfangen können.
Wie habt ihr die Nummern rausgekriegt?
Google-Cache. Weil die Seiten waren ja nicht mehr erreichbar in Ägypten. Und wir hatten die Nummer nicht gehabt, also mussten wir auf den Google-Cache zurückkeilen. Wir haben auf der ganzen Welt angefaxed. Und ich habe da eine recht hohe Fax-Rechnung produziert. Und das hat funktioniert. Also wir haben durch ein großes, massives Fax-Aufkommen, haben wir die Nummern gestreut und sie wurden angerufen. Und natürlich dann auch noch im nächsten Schritt, ein Reporter von Al-Jazeera gefragt, die haben wir bei Ägypten nicht erreicht, für Libyen haben wir sie erreicht. Heißt? Dass die, den Menschen, die sie vor Ort treffen, die Nummer einfach in die Hand drücken.
Okay, sie haben aber nicht irgendwie, sondern Laufschrift im Fernsehen eingeblendet.
Nee, aber dafür im Live-Blog. Also sie haben es auch weiterverbreitet, unser Telecomix-Fax. Ja, das ist das Mittel der Wahl gewesen. Wir faxen es halt mal hin.
Es ist ja so, dass du erzählt hast, sie hätte 600 Leitungen, aber ein Großteil davon waren einzelne Rufnummern, wo mehrere Leute anrufen könnten. Das heißt, es gibt einen Blog von Rufnummern, die man anrufen kann, um ins Internet zu kommen. Haben die Mächtigen nicht dann wiederum die Möglichkeit, diese Rufnummern zu sperren?
Die hätten sie, ja. Das Risiko bestand. In Ägypten ist das nicht passiert. In Libyen ist das jetzt passiert. Unsere Einrufnummer in Düsseldorf ist teilweise nicht erreichbar. Sie ist nicht von überall aus erreichbar. Teilweise ist sie blockiert.
Wie schnell könnt ihr da neue Nummern in Beschlag nehmen?
Nicht so schnell. Also einzelne Nummern ja, ganze modernen Bänke dahinter nein, das geht nicht so schnell. Wir haben momentan zum Glück noch das FDN laufen, das ist auch noch nicht blockiert. Und wir haben als Backup noch ein weiteres Projekt hier in Deutschland sitzen, das auf Zuruf innerhalb von 12 Stunden 30 Leitungen bekommt.
Okay, aber das ist nicht eine ernsthafte Gefahr.
Diese Gefahr besteht ja.
Das heißt, ihr müsst dann auch immer gucken, dass die Nummern nicht zu weit verbreitet werden, nicht zu weit bekannt.
Sobald es öffentlich ist, sobald wir es verbreiten, ist es da und kann gesperrt werden. Das Risiko besteht immer, da kommen wir auch nicht ran rum.
Also wenn jemand Nummernblöcke spenden kann?
Also wenn jemand Leitungen hat, so unglaublich viele davon, die auf einer Nummer zusammenlaufen, dann...
Eingelt Folgendes! Jetzt anrufen! 0331 70 97 110 So, es geht also darüber, die Kontrolle zu behalten, um Kommunikation auf euch zu halten. Wir hören jetzt einen Song, der passend zum Thema ist. Er heißt das von Professor Click und er heißt All Control. Und wir reden gleich noch eine halbe Stunde weiter darüber, wie wir uns ein Paket zusammenschnüren, damit wir hier, falls unsere Regierung beschließt, Alter, wir machen das Internet aus, dass wir so ein Notfallpaket haben. Das wird, ich vermute, nach dem, was ich bis heute im Chaosradio gehört habe, vor allem aus alter Technik bestehen. Aber wir werden gleich mal gucken, wie das so aussehen kann. Bevor wir das klären, machen wir aber das Fritz-Info mit Nachrichten, Wetter und Verkehr und wie gesagt vorher noch Professor Click, All Control im Hard Remix.
Ja, für alle, die jetzt denken, ey, da ist ja gar nix.
Richtig, ohne Rundfunkgebühren wär hier auch gar nix.
Pritz.
Powered bei eurer Rundfunkgebühr. Mit?
Ach so, mit drei ist natürlich, oh Gott, ganz vergessen, der Typ ohne Computer ist wieder im Studio und macht Nachrichten.
Ja, den Film brauche ich doch, wenn du das sagst. Bahnreisende müssen morgen Vormittag erneut mit Behinderungen rechnen. Wie die Lokführer-Gewerkschaft GDL mitteilte, soll es für 8.30 Uhr bis 11.30 Uhr Warnstreiks geben. Bestreikt werden die Deutsche Bahn und sechs Privatbahnen. Die Berliner S-Bahn soll diesmal aber nicht bestreikt werden. Schon am Dienstagmorgen hatten Warnstreik den Schienenverkehr für zwei Stunden weitestgehend lahmgelegt. Die GDL will einheitliche Tarifbedingungen für die rund 26.000 Lokführer in Deutschland durchsetzen. In Libyen gehen regierungsteuer Truppen offenbar weiter brutal gegen Aufständische und Protestierende vor. Es wird von zahlreichen Toten berichtet. Regierungen in aller Welt arbeiten mit Hochdruck daran, ihre Staatsbürger aus dem Land zu holen. Die deutsche Marine schickte drei Schiffe. Angesichts der Gewalt in Libyen wächst der internationale Druck auf das Regime. Die Europäische Union beantragte beim UNO-Menschenrechtsrat den Ausschluss des nordafrikanischen Landes. Darüber soll morgen in Genf beraten werden. Nach der Aberkennung des Doktortitels prüft die Universität bei Reuth, ob Verteidigungsminister zu Guttenberg die Hochschule bewusst getäuscht hat. Eine Kommission soll das Verhalten des Ministers untersuchen und bewerten. Der Ältestenrat des Bundestags will erst Mitte März entscheiden, ob die Doktorarbeit auch vom Parlament überprüft wird. SPD und Grüne werfen Union und FDP vor, sie wollten eine rasche Aufklärung verhindern. Nordrhein-Westfalen schafft zum nächsten Wintersemester die Studiengebühren ab. Das hat der Landtag mit den Stimmen der Regierungsparteien SPD und Grüne und der oppositionellen Linken entschieden. Bislang hatten die Hochschulen von ihren Studenten pro Semester 500 Euro kassiert. Mit der Abschaffung der Studiengebühren hat NRW-Ministerpräsidentin Kraft eines ihrer großen Wahlversprechen eingelöst. In der Fußball-Europa-League steht Leverkusen im Viertelfinale. Der VfB Stuttgart ist dagegen ausgeschieden. Die Stuttgarter an der Lage im eigenen Stadion Benfica Lissamon mit 0 zu 2. Das Schinnspiel hatten die Schwaben bereits mit 1 zu 2 verloren. Leverkusen setzte sich beim ukrainischen Club Rakov mit 2 zu 0 durch. Schon die erste Partie hatten die Leverkusen damit 4 zu 0 deutlich für sich entscheiden können. Mit den aktuellen Temperaturen in Berlin und Brandenburg währte zwischen minus 5 und minus 8 Grad. Die Nacht ist wenig bewirkt und meist auch sternenklar. Und es ist ziemlich kalt draußen wieder mal. Die T-Satte liegen heute bei minus 13 Grad. Tagsüber wechseln sich dann Sonne und Wolken ab, es bleibt trocken. Die Höchstsatte liegen dann am Freitag zwischen minus 4 und einem Grad plus. Eine Meldung nur aus dem Stadtverkehr Berlin. Der betrifft immer noch den Stadtring 100 Richtung Wedding zwischen dem Spandauer Damm und dem Dreieck Charlottenburg. Dort staute sich aktuell immer noch bei drei Kilometern.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des Airbaby.
Barein, zum 15. Februar verringerte sich das Datenvolumen des Landes um 10 bis 20 Prozent. Wahrscheinlich soll so die Protestbewegung zensiert werden, nachdem es zu blutigen Auseinandersetzungen mit die Militär gekommen war. Wie lange die Störung dauern wird, ist noch unklar. Zum Schluss noch eine Entwarnung für Ägypten. Hier fließt der Datenverkehr seit Ende des letzten Monats wieder flüssig.
Wir wünschen eine gute Fahrt.
Die Playlist auf fritz.de. Und das Auge hört mit man.
Die zwei Sprechstunden. Chaos Radio, eine halbe Stunde haben wir noch. Heute mit Markus Trichter, das ist meine Gestalt. Und zu Gast im Studio sind heute Herr Urbach, der gerade so eben wieder ins Mikrofon zurückfindet. Na, sind Sie schon da? Sind Sie schon da?
Ja, ich bin da.
Das ist unglaublich. Ich bin der Nerd im Studio. Das ist das reine Chaos.
Ich musste Kaffee holen.
Ja, ich musste kommen. Gott des Willen. Ebenfalls am Start und immer brav dabei Elektra Wagenrad. Hallo und guten Abend. Und gerade noch irgendwo verschollen ist der Wetterfrosch. Der hat wahrscheinlich Angst bekommen, dass jetzt doch noch ein Anrufer anruft. Genau, eine halbe Stunde habt ihr noch Zeit, um Fragen zu stellen. Es geht um Internet in Krisengebieten. Also in Gebieten, wo kein Internet ist oder weniger. Ich hab's gerade in der Datenverkehrsmeldung gehört. In Bahrain wurde das Netz einfach schmaler gemacht. Wir haben heute schon über zahlreiche Projekte gesprochen, wo es darum ging, dass man einfach Netz wieder anstellen bringt oder Kommunikation anstellen bringt, wo keine mehr ist. Jetzt frage ich mich, kann man sowas auch aufheben, Herr Urbach? Also das Netz ist schmaler, kann man so irgendwie wieder mehr Bandbreite dazu geben?
Nicht so ohne Weiteres. Also einfach auch nur durch mehr Uplinks bereitstellen, wie wir es auch jetzt bereits tun. Wenn das Netz gedrosselt wird, dann können wir da nicht viel machen. Das ist dann einfach eine technische Konfiguration der Router.
Okay, also was wir hier machen können mit den Mitteln, die wir heute hier besprechen, die sozusagen überhaupt Kommunikation an den Start bringen, mit der Bandbreite, das müssen wir dann mal später bearbeiten. Gibt es da schon irgendwie so Zukunftsszenarien? Wie kriege ich mehr Bandbreite an Orte, die wenig Bandbreite haben?
Darüber machen wir uns momentan noch wenig Gedanken, denn erstmal jetzt darum überhaupt, da irgendwo reinzuhalten.
Entschuldigung, aber du musst dir doch sozusagen noch über die Hand machen. Du hast doch selber erzählt, dass das sehr wichtig gewesen wäre, gerade in Ägypten.
Ja, aber wir haben einfach momentan nicht die technische, wir haben nicht die Technologie dafür.
Du musst aber jetzt noch erzählen, warum das ist, also warum ihr eigentlich noch mehr Bandbreite hättet brauchen können.
Wir glauben zwar nicht an Logs bei Telecomix, aber gerade wenn wir neue Geräte an den Start bringen, gucken wir schon mal nach, so funktionieren die richtig, wegen Debugging halt einfach, dann lassen wir doch Logs mitlaufen. Und wir hatten einen Zugangsknoten, da rief jemand an.
Also, wie gesagt, auch immer zusammengehört, also in Ägypten kein Internet mehr, die Leute konnten aber außerhalb von Ägypten Telefonnummer anrufen und da wiederum war dann Internet dran und das ist also eine Verbindung, die ist 56K, das ist so ähnlich, GPHS, also das ist ein langsames Mobilfunknetz, was es überhaupt gibt und noch ein bisschen langsamer diese Verbindung. Und dann ist Folgendes passiert.
Und dann schauten wir so in die Logs rein und plötzlich sahen wir, dass der Teilnehmer sich die neueste Folge von How I Met Your Mother heruntergeladen hat und das war irgendwie ja fast schon zum Lachen gewesen. So, hey, ich hab nichts, ich lad mir einen Film runter und eine Serie.
Unglaublich. Und der Anrufer kam von wo?
Der kam aus Ägypten.
Ja, könnt ihr mal sehen, wozu man so ein Netz überall braucht. Wir haben jetzt die ganze Zeit schon drüber geredet, wie man Netz nach Afrika bekommt oder nach Timor oder Ägypten oder Libyen. Und die Frage ist, ein bisschen die kleine Angst, gerade Nerds neigen ein bisschen zur Paranoia, was passiert, wenn jetzt hier in Deutschland das Internet abgeschaltet wird? Wir wollen jetzt noch zum Schluss eine kleine Kiste backen, wo alles drin ist, was wir brauchen, um zu kommunizieren. Also möglicherweise nicht mal mit dem Netz, aber irgendwie mit anderen Leuten und möglichst nicht in echt, sondern übers Gerät.
Also kann man eigentlich ganz grundlegend anfangen bei Funkgeräten.
Funkgeräten?
Ja, da fällt Telefone, aber wenn wir jetzt nicht von Scheinzeitenumgebung ausgehen, dann sollte auf jeden Fall ein, zwei WLAN-Geräte und WLAN-Antennen dabei sein. WLAN-Antennen, da gibt es ja so welche, die rundherum strahlen, oder solche gerichteten Antennen, dass man wirklich eine weitere Verbindung über mehrere Kilometer von einem Punkt zum anderen Punkt überbrücken kann. So Richtfunkantennen für den WLAN-Bereich zwei Stück und entsprechende Geräte, dass man darüber schon mal Netzwerk bekommen kann, wäre auf jeden Fall schon mal praktisch, um sich an den nächsten Nachbarn anzuschließen.
Also ich würde da so eine WAN-DAN-Strategie vorschlagen. Solange das Telefonnetz noch geht, kann man analoge Modems verwenden. Die Möglichkeit besteht dann immer noch.
Wo kriege ich heutzutage noch analoges Modem her?
Gibt es sowas überhaupt noch?
Die SDN-Karten natürlich auch nicht vergessen, oder?
Gibt es immer noch, weil es gibt immer noch Leute, die irgendwo sitzen und nur eine analoge Telefonleitung haben und sonst nichts.
Und mal ganz dumm gesagt, in jedem aktuellen Dell Notebook ist ein Modem drinne. Also die meisten Leute haben ihren Notebooks Modems drinne und vergessen sie vollkommen, weil sie sie halt nicht brauchen. Aber gut, jetzt im Mac ist es nicht drinne, aber so in einem Dell, in einem Acer, überall sind noch Modems eingebaut.
Ein weiterer Grund, sich einen Laptop zu kaufen, kein festen Computer.
Ich denke aber, es wird mittlerweile langsam verschwinden aus den Notebooks, aber ein älteres Gerät, was vielleicht drei, vier Jahre alt ist, dürfte es in aller Regel noch drin haben. Gut, aber das ist die Strategie, die noch funktioniert, wenn es noch ein funktionierendes Telefonnetz gibt. Aber was, wenn es das auch nicht mehr gibt oder nie vorhanden war?
Dann haben wir eine Meshpotato dabei.
Ja, aber die Meshpotato kann nur auf kurze Entfernung kommunizieren. Man braucht dann schon relativ viele Meshpotatos. Um vielleicht eine Stadt zu vernetzen, dass also innerhalb einer Stadt noch Kommunikation stattfindet, dafür geht es noch. Um vorzugreifen, der allerletzte Resort, das ist das allerletzte Mittel, auf das man zurückgreifen kann, ist Kurzwellenfunk. Das ist dann wirklich die allerletzte Methode.
Jetzt irgendwie um Gespräche zu führen oder ist das eigentlich um Datenverkehr zu haben?
Da kann man auch Datenverkehr darüber machen. Und zwar braucht man dafür wirklich nur ein Laptop und eine Soundkarte oder irgendeine Art von Computer und eine Soundkarte. Da gibt es Software. Für Linux gibt es eine Software, die heißt Soundmodem. Und die emuliert dann quasi einen Kurzwellenmodem über die Soundkarte.
Und da brauche ich aber noch eine Gegenstelle. Wie weit kann die dann weg sein?
Das hängt von dem verwendeten Funkgerät und von der Datenrate ab.
Wir wollen ja gerade die Christi für zu Hause sagen. Es muss ja irgendwas sein, was du sagen kannst, nicht so groß wie mein Zimmer, sondern halt haushaltsüblich, sage ich mal.
Haushaltsüblich, heute auch kaum noch, aber gibt es immer noch die CB-Funktechnik, da kann man Reichweiten zwischen 30 und 70 Kilometern erzielen unter guten Bedingungen mit einem einzelnen Gerät.
Genau, wir haben während der Ägypten-Sache mit Hemradio den Funkabgehörten auch gemoßt über Hemradio. Das ist eine Funktechnologie, die irgendwie funktioniert. Für mich ist das Magie. Da gibt es aber auch durchaus Leute, die richtig Ahnung von haben. Bei Hemradio haben wir auch Erfolge mit erzielt, dass wir mit Leuten kommuniziert haben, über Morse in dem Fall. Wir haben auch die Nummern gemoßt gehabt, also so war das möglich.
Ein Morse-Alphabet?
Ja, das ist nicht umsonst erfunden worden, das funktioniert auch immer noch nach wie vor. Ein Leitspruch von Telecomix ist, to provide every means of communications available. Und das Available ist das ganz Wichtige dabei. Wenn nur Funk da ist, nutzen wir Funk.
Was Elektra vorgestellt hat, ist, sie kommunizieren mit Fiepen und Rauschen. Und da gibt es verschiedene Standards, welche Frequenz, welche Zeichen bedeutet. Das ist in diesem Soundmodem, was du vorgestellt hast, auf jeden Fall enthalten in dieser Software, dass du da alle möglichen Standards mit sprechen kannst. Und worüber dann dieses Tonsignal transferiert wird, ob das jetzt vielleicht auch einfach ein Radiosender ist. Also Elektra hat bestimmt schon mehr FM-Radiosender mal gebaut.
Wie, möglicherweise könnten wir hier sozusagen einfach eine Datenverbindung aufbauen?
Natürlich, wir können auch hier über Radio Fizz jetzt live ein paar Bits senden. Und dann können das Leute mit ihren Hemradio Stations oder einfach mit ihren Laptops, einer Soundkarte und einem Mikrofon dran direkt dekodieren.
Wir schicken Stucksett über unsere Welle, geil!
Genau, dann kannst du auch über ein Feldtelefon eine Datentäterverbindung machen.
Kann man einfach als Sounddatei ablegen und dann abspielen, dann können die Leute die Daten entfangen.
Das hört sich ja großartig an. Ganz ehrlich, Hand auf Herz, wie viele davon habt ihr zu Hause rumliegen? Von den Sachen, die wir gerade vorgestellt haben? Okay, Herr Urbach ist raus.
Nee, der Herr Urbach ist drinnen. Herr Funkgeräte. Wir hatten nämlich ganz wenig, der Herr Urbach. Tatsächlich, wieso? Ich bin gerade nach Berlin gezogen und mein Zeug steht noch in Hessen.
Oh mein Gott, wenn jetzt das Netz ausfällt.
Ja, bin ich taub und blind.
Aber Hessen ist versorgt.
Hessen ist versorgt, ja. Also ich habe momentan nur meinen Laptop hier. Das Kaimodem hat gar nichts. Ich wäre ziemlich taub und blind. Wenn ich mein Zeug hier hätte, hätte ich wenigstens Modem, ISDN-Karten und Funk, also WLAN-Verbindungen. Das hätte ich. Ich kann jedem wirklich nur empfehlen, sich dringend irgendwie nochmal Modem zu besorgen. Ich habe am besten auch einen Ex-Handles, wenn der Rechner kaputt geht, dass man einfach einen anderen Rechner ranpacken kann. Die gibt es recht günstig auf diversen Online-Marktplätzen. Wahrscheinlich sind sie nach dieser Sendung teurer dann.
Plötzlich ja auch von in der Modem-Branche, verstehe ich.
eBay für ein paar Euro wird es da bestimmt einige geben.
Und apropos Modems, wir brauchen Modems, ganz viele davon.
Das wollte ich gerade fragen. Ihr habt ja diese Nummer gebracht, also ihr stellt irgendwo Rechner hin. Ihr habt jetzt einen großen Kooperationspartner. Ihr sammelt jetzt aber nur Modems.
Ihr sammelt jetzt nicht irgendwie Rechner? Ich brauche kein Rechner sammeln, wenn ich keine Modems habe. Also Rechner sind einfacher zu bekommen als Modems heutzutage. Okay, verstehe. Modems wären ganz super. Wenn man im Berliner Raum ist, kann man die Donnerstags in CCC Berlin abgeben. Da werden die dann eingesammelt. Und dann werden die von Telecomix weiterverwertet.
Okay, egal. Wenn welche da sind, dann...
Also ich nehme auch 144er Modems.
Du wolltest gerade sagen, sonst habe ich noch zu Hause liegen, glaube ich.
Da kann ich aushelfen.
Okay, jetzt haben wir tatsächlich noch einen Anrufer. Christian.
Ich habe zwei Fragen im Endeffekt. Beide vielleicht etwas sicherheitskritisch. Und zwar ist es einmal bezüglich dem Problem, dass in Libyen ja die Nummern gesperrt werden und neue Telefonnummern relativ schwer zu beschaffen sind. Ob es da irgendwelche Wege dran vorbei gibt mit, ich sage einfach mal, einem Stapel SIM-Karten, die eine Rufnummerweiterleitung auf den endgültigen Zugangspunkt machen. Ob sowas schon mal irgendwie gecheckt wurde, ob das geht? Und die zweite Sache wäre im Bezug auf die Mesh-Netzwerke, puncto Ortungssicherheit. Man kennt es irgendwie von damals CB-Funk, wenn sie dann irgendwie um einen Block fahren und nach dir suchen.
Also zu den Rufnummern, wir haben den Effekt der Reihe, dass Nummern blockiert sind. Einfach zum Gehen sind die nicht. Über Mobilfunknetze haben wir noch nicht probiert. Einfach auch, weil wenn jemand eine Mobilfunknummer aus dem Ausland anruft, diese Kosten explodieren schlagartig. Und es ist so schon teuer genug für die Leute, die oft nicht wirklich viel Geld haben. Und das wollen wir ihnen auch nicht zumuten. Unter Umständen erkennen sie es nicht, dass sie eine Mobilfunknummer anrufen, die unglaublich teuer wird, wenn sie sie anrufen.
Na, aber wäre das nicht tatsächlich eine Möglichkeit? Ihr könntet euch ja auch irgendwie Voice-over-IP-Nummern...
Voice-over-IP und Modems will nicht wirklich zusammen funktionieren.
Tatsächlich?
Da arbeiten wir noch dran. Da gibt es gerade einen ZIP-Provider in Polen, der gerade was deploit, was das betrifft. Momentan ist das Protokoll nicht auf Modems ausgelegt und will nicht zusammenarbeiten.
Da ist dann die Soundqualität so schlecht? Die Signale?
Zu hohe Verlustrate der Daten. Die Lizenz ist zu hoch.
Für Voice-over-IP wird ein Audiokodec verwendet, der verlustbehaftet ist. Bei der Datenübertragung kommt es darauf an, dass das sehr präzise übertragen wird. Der Codec, der die Datenbandbreite reduziert, damit Voice-over-IP leichter möglich wird, der schneidet genau die Sachen weg. Mit dem Codec G711 dürfte es vielleicht gehen, aber jetzt schweife ich ab und wir kommen zu sehr dicht.
Die Idee besteht schon, dass man eine Nummer-Weiterleitung macht, aber da gibt es noch ein paar Probleme. Zur zweiten Frage, warum sollte man Mesh-Netzwerke orten wollen? Du willst einfach fragen, ob das geht und wie man sich da verschützen kann.
Rein theoretisch, ob das irgendwie angedacht ist, weil im schlimmsten Fall kommunizieren da ja zwei Lager, sage ich mal, irgendwie. Und wenn Papa Staat da hinterher ist, der weiß, was die sich einfallen lassen.
Ja, du hast recht, das ist möglich. Also jede Radioübertragung ist im Prinzip ortbar. Man kann die anpeilen, also bis zu ihrer Reichweite, das ist möglich. Genauso kann man auch die Sendemasten von Radio Fritz ganz einfach aufspüren, wenn man dann mit einer Richtantenne durch die Gegend läuft und die einfach anpeilt. Es gibt aber sogar noch was, also wenn zum Beispiel die Kommunikation wirklich nur auf einzelne Worte oder Sätze beschränkt ist, dann kann man das so langsam und bei so einer niedrigen Senderate machen, dass man das mit dem Empfänger gar nicht mehr empfangen kann. Das geht dann im Rauschteppich unter. Funkamateure verwenden das, um mit unglaublich niedriger Sendeleistung um die Welt rumzufunken. Da gibt es dann so eine Software, die analysiert das Rauschen mit einer Fourier-Transformation. Und man kann auf dem Display quasi diese Mausezeichen sehen. Das lässt sich kaum nachweisen. Also da muss man wirklich genau die Frequenz wissen, auf der das stattfindet. Ist aber wahrscheinlich für die meisten Leute vollkommen unrealistisch, so etwas zu unternehmen.
Also es gibt theoretisch eine theoretische Umgebung, aber sozusagen für das Mesh-Netzwerk ist es nicht praktikal?
Also im Expertenmodus kann man zum Beispiel so eine Information, wie hier wird gerade geschossen, die kann man in den Rauschlevel des Empfängers integrieren. Und dann fällt den Behörden das gar nicht auf, wenn ihnen die Frequenz nicht bekannt ist.
Da muss man ja auch unterscheiden, was man ortet. Ob man jetzt einen Teilnehmer ortet, der einfach am Netzwerk hängt oder einen Teilnehmer orten will, der etwas bestimmtes kommuniziert. Und da gibt es ja auch Mittel und Wege, wie man Leute anonym an solchen Netzen und an der Publikation von Inhalten teil lassen kann. Oder auch eben verschlüsselt, dass man eben gar nicht sieht, was dort genau übertragen wird. Und dann sieht man, okay, da gibt es jemand, der hängt da irgendwie am Netzwerk, hat vielleicht auch Internet, aber ob er jetzt wirklich das veröffentlicht hat, was am anderen herausfällt, ist dann nicht zu rauhrenbar.
Ein Nachtrag noch zu den Mesh-Netzwerken. Die Geräte haben relativ wenig Leistung und die werden dann unter Umständen auch zahlreich und können autonom arbeiten. Man kann es schon sehr schwer machen. Also da müssten dann quasi in dem Moment, wo die Revolution am Gange ist, müssten sie Tage damit zubringen, diese einzelnen Geräte aufzuspüren, die sich dann auch noch schönerweise immer wenn eins ausfällt, wenn sie noch eine Alternative haben, einen neuen Pfad bilden. Das ist schon sehr schwer. Ich glaube kaum, dass es in so einem richtigen Krisenmoment, dass da jemand noch Zeit und Lust hat, dem nachzugehen.
Das ist sozusagen einer der Vorteile, dass es ja aus vielen einzelnen Einheiten besteht. Man müsste das, um das Netz zu zerstören, alle auf einen Schlag wegnehmen.
Da müsste man sehr viele aus dem Verkehr ziehen, gewissermaßen.
Wie hoch ist die Rate in so einer Stadt, wenn die gut verteilt sind?
Du meinst, wie viele Geräte man auch bräuchte. Wenn man keine Redundanz hat, wenn man immer nur eine Verbindung hat, dann kann man das Netz natürlich auch leicht stilllegen. Im Prinzip wird das Netz umso besser, je mehr Geräte daran beteiligt sind. Es gibt mittlerweile sehr viele Geräte, die man dafür hernehmen kann. Es gibt da diese Linux-Distribution OpenWrt. Hier kann man die ganzen Routing-Protokolle installieren. Die haben alle diese Möglichkeit und da kann man mittlerweile, ich weiß nicht, einen großen Prozentsatz des Marktes damit ausstatten und damit solche Netze aufbauen.
Christian, Frage beantwortet?
Absolut, ich sage besten Dank und ein super klasse Projekt auf jeden Fall.
Vielen Dank und schönen Abend dir noch. Bis denn, tschüss. Liebe Hörer, wir müssen ernsthaft mal reden. Es ist jetzt 10 vor 12. Diese Sendung geht 2 Stunden, wir haben jetzt noch 10 Minuten. Und jetzt ruft ihr an. Was zur Hölle habt ihr ja an? Jetzt anrufen 0331 77 91 10. Nicht vorher verstanden. Peter. Warum rufst du es jetzt an? Was ist denn hier los?
Ja, ich hab ganz entspannt zugehört.
Ich hab euch immer gesagt, wir dürfen die Sendung nicht so spannend machen. Die Leute rufen nicht an, die müssen sich langweilen. Die müssen sich so langweilen, dass sie hier anrufen.
Okay.
Aber du hast noch eine Frage.
Ja, ich hätte eine Frage an CCC. Und zwar, es ist jetzt irgendwie noch nicht gefallen, oder ich hab es jetzt wirklich verpasst, aber ich glaub nicht. Wie wird jetzt, ihr nennt das ein Mashed-Potato, ne?
Mashed-Potato, das ist ein Gerät, das ist unabhängig von CCC.
Genau, das Gerät für Krisengebiete, was ihr gesagt habt, in diesen Entwicklungsländern vornehmlich. Ja, wie wird das jetzt, kann ich es mit normalen Batterien betreiben? Oder hat das eine Art Akku? Was hat das?
Das Gerät hat einen Anschluss für ein Telefon, das hat einen Anschluss für einen Netzwerkkabel und das hat noch eine DC-Buchse. Und über alle drei Buchsen kannst du da Spannung reinjagen. Zwischen 9 und 40 Volt ist der Bereich, in dem es funktioniert. Das ist ein recht großer Eingangsbereich.
DC heißt diese kleine Strom-Gleichspannungsbuchse, die man eigentlich in jedem technischen Gerät mit dem kleinen schwarzen Rundfleck hat.
Man kann es über das Telefonkabel, übers Netzwerkkabel speisen. Es nimmt Gleichspannung und wenn man aus Versehen mal die Polarität umdreht, dann geht es nicht kaputt. Wenn man zu hohe Gleichspannung reichen macht, dann geht eine Schutzschaltung an und da bricht es einfach. Es ist dafür gemacht, dass Leute, die technisch nicht versiert sind, die Dinge in die Hand nehmen und irgendwas damit tun und sie gehen nicht kaputt.
Okay, und im Krisenfall, wenn wir keinen Strom haben, wenn die Leute dort keinen Strom haben?
Angenommen, du bist in einem Katastrophengebiet, wo nach einer Explosion im Vulkanausbruch irgendwelche schrottigen Autos rumstehen, nimmst du dir einfach eine alte Autobatterie oder eine Lastwagenbatterie. Mit einer Lastwagenbatterie wird das Gerät mehrere Wochen arbeiten.
Okay, ja und Batterien gehen aber gar nicht oder gehen nicht?
Doch, natürlich das geht auch. Also du bräuchtest dann halt irgendwie ein Batteriefach, wo du mehrere Batterien einlegen kannst. Wie gesagt, die Mindestspannung ist 9 Volt. Um zu telefonieren, wenn es nur funken soll, dann tun es auch 3, 3 Volt.
Wie groß muss die Solarzelle sein?
Ja, Solarzelle. Das hängt vom Gebiet ab. Also in Südafrika kommt man mit einem 10 Watt Solarpanel hin. Das ist wie groß? 10 Watt Solarpanel, das ist ungefähr 20 x 30 cm groß.
Und ein A4-Blatt?
Das kriegt man über Ebay für 40 Euro. Aber in unseren Breiten, zum Beispiel im Winter, jetzt haben wir gerade den düstesten Monat, oder im Januar muss man schon ein sehr großes Solarpanel haben, um da überhaupt noch ausreichend Energie ernten zu können, weil die Sonneneinstrahlung einfach zu gering ist.
Gibt es irgendwie so noch Taschendynamos oder was auch immer?
Selbstverständlich.
Kann man alles machen?
Kann man alles machen. Also irgendwas mit einer Kobel dran. Windkraft bietet sich in dem Fall an. Es gibt viele Möglichkeiten. In der zivilisierten Welt, nach so einer Katastrophe, steht genügend Gerät rum, was man einfach hernehmen kann. Autobatterien, Lkw-Batterien haben 12 Volt. Auch eine Batterie vor einer Alarmanlage geht. Oder Monozellen aus der Taschenlampe.
Man kann jeden Motor auch als Generator benutzen, einfach dran drehen, dann kommt da wieder Strom raus.
Eine ganz kurze Frage noch. Wie heißt denn bitte die URL, wo das Internet gesaved wird?
Oder was ihr vorhin gesagt habt? Das Internetarchiv, das kanntest du noch nicht. Unglaublich.
Kein Anspruch auf Vollständigkeit an dieser Stelle?
Früher war es mal sehr vollständig. Das heißt archive.org, also archive mit v.org.
Mittlerweile beschränken sich darauf, bestimmte Webseiten mehr oder weniger semi-regelmäßig aufzunehmen. Ich habe mal in meinem Blog geguckt, da war es dann so, ich glaube im Halbjahresrhythmus haben sie einen Snapshot in diese Datenbank reingeladen. Aber vollständig ist es in der Tat nicht mehr. Aber doch sehr interessant.
Ich habe das früher benutzt, um esoterische Treiber von irgendwelchen Windows-Geräten runterzuladen, wo die Firma schon lange nicht mehr existiert hat, weil sie die HTTP-Downloads einfach archiviert haben. Davon haben sie mittlerweile Raumsabstand genommen. Das passt einfach nicht mehr in 4 Terabyte.
Das ist richtig.
Dann hoffe ich, dass das Gerät für uns zu kaufen ist. Oder ist es jetzt schon zu kaufen für uns?
Das ist zu kaufen. Das wird vertrieben unter anderem von der Firma Atcom in China, in Shenzhen. Da kann man das bestellen. Oder in Südafrika.
Kennt ihr Bang, die Firma aus China? Geschrieben.
Sagt mir jetzt nichts.
Die hat ganz viele Sachen gemacht für Konsolen. Ganz speziell, wo man rumslagen konnte. Ganz coole Sachen, die es sonst nirgendwo gab. Auf jeden Fall, es gilt auch nicht, Leute.
Auf jeden Fall, das Gerät kann man direkt beim Hersteller kaufen.
Ja, das ist super. Und ja, dann viel Erfolg damit. Und ich würde echt cool finden, wenn ich meinen alten Game Boy nehmen könnte, die Batterie nehmen könnte und es damit betreiben könnte. Ich habe heute auch Batterien gekauft, die sind haltbar bis 2018, 2017 oder so.
Na alles klar, einfach den passenden Adapter noch dazu anschaffen und dann geht das klar. Super, alles klar. Bis dann, tschüss. So, na schön, zum Schluss doch noch ein paar Anrufe, meine Güte. So, wir sind jetzt fast schon wieder am Ende.
Wir sollten auf jeden Fall noch hinweisen.
Wait, ich muss ehrlich sagen, bevor wir, also nachdem wir jetzt auch noch auf Dinge hingewiesen haben und noch eine Musik gespielt haben, dann kommt Henrik Schröder mit dem neuen Fall, denn das Chaosradio ist jetzt gleich zu Ende. Aber Wetterforscht hat noch einen Hinweis? Oder zwei oder drei?
Eigentlich nur einen kurzen, und zwar wo man unter anderem auch Elektra häufiger findet und wer sich auch mit diesem ganzen, ja, wie macht man ein WLAN-Netzwerk autonomerweise beschäftigt, sind die Freifunker, die hatten auch im Oktober letzten Jahres 2010 eine Sendung hier im Chaosradio gemacht. Die treffen sich jeden Mittwoch in der Berliner Sea-Base, eine abgestürzene Raumstation an der Jernobitsbrücke. Immer so am späteren Abend, so ab 9 Uhr, geht es dann da rund.
Einfach mal nach Sea-Base googeln, dann findet man das.
Genau. Und da, wer sich für diese Sachen interessiert, findet da auf jeden Fall Anschluss. Und ansonsten werden wir die Wiki-Seite zu dieser Sendung noch bestimmt etwas pflegen und ein paar Links.
Bestimmt macht das noch irgendjemand, glaube ich.
Es ist ein Wiki.
Es ist ein Wiki. Es kann ja jeder arbeiten. Deswegen machen es auch alle. Das ist genauso wie putzen in der Wiki.
Alle, die heute nicht angerufen haben, müssen das Wiki pflegen.
Werter Frosch, Elektra Wagenrad und Herr Urbach, vielen Dank für dieses Chaosradio. Wir wissen jetzt, wie wir beim Krisenfall an Internet kommen oder zumindest untereinander kommunizieren können. Diese ganze Sendung gibt es natürlich auch als Podcast unter chaosradio.de. Die wird sie wahrscheinlich auftauchen. Auch auf fritz.de wird das natürlich geben. Ich empfehle mich an dieser Stelle und mir bleibt natürlich nur noch eins zu sagen, was wirklich wichtig ist und was ihr beherzigen solltet. Ich glaube, ich habe es schon ein paarmal gesagt, man kann sich oft genug sagen, macht immer schön eure Back-ups und lasst euch nicht überwachen.